on sunday the indianapolis colts had a
24-7
lead over the pittsburgh steelers in the
second half the steelers
finally woke up from a month-long
funk and pulled off the victory over
indianapolis we took a closer look at
that game and as always we break it down
into various categories here on pftpm
and shireen let's start with
after closer inspection of that
pittsburgh win
best player on the field who have you
selected
i picked tj white mike and he had three
tackles two sacks and a forced fumble
and i just thought that strip sack
there early in the second quarter 1437
left
was huge because at best the steelers
were looking at being down
21-0 at halftime but they picked it up
ran it to three yard lines and it was it
still took the offense three plays to
get in the end zone from the three mike
and but that to me was a turning point
because
if they don't score in that first half i
think that
ben roethlisberger's speech at halftime
would have been
for null and void because they would
have been so far behind and then
obviously the colts came out and got the
field goal so it would have been 24
nothing at that point and i don't know
that's just a steep climb back
for a team and i just thought that that
play was huge
and you know when you start talking
about defense player of the year mike
i think it's going to be a very
difficult decision to pick between t.j
watt and aaron donald and
mike tomlin said today that tj watt
is a guy from another planet and and i
think he is
let's hear from mike tomlin you know
tj's visiting from another planet
to be quite honest with you um he has
freakishly unique talent
coupled with freakishly unique work
habits and mindset
and it produces what you guys witness
every week which in my opinion
is defensive player to your quality
you know sharing i asked tj what after
the game on sunday if he thinks about
cares about wants to be in the
conversation for defensive player of the
year an award his brother jj
has won three times tj said i'd rather
win the super bowl now that wasn't a dig
at his brother and frankly
when you consider what
mike tomlin said about tj watt let's
spin it forward
shall we because that same alien dna
is inside the body of jj watt if jj
doesn't return to the texans and i think
they'll respect his wishes if he asks to
be released or traded
could you imagine jj and tj on the field
at the same time next year for the
pittsburgh steelers and i know some
would say well they don't really need
him they've got plenty of great players
well
the more guys you put in the defensive
line rotation the better off you
are and the idea of both of those guys
playing for that steelers defense
should scare the crap out of every other
quarterback in the afc north and beyond
shireen
absolutely look what what washington's
down with that rotation and the steelers
have had their rotation and it's been
great
and jj's on the downside of his career
mike so he needs to get
in a spot where he is in a rotation
where he doesn't have to produce
every single play and he doesn't have to
make those game-changing plays and i
think if he plays fewer snaps
he's able to do that and with the
steelers certainly he would play a
lesser role and that would be perfect
for him on the downside of his career
you know for me it's ben roethlisberger
as the player of the game he's taken so
much crap
although he deserves plenty of it he
hasn't played well and he said when you
play like pooh i think he used the word
poo
you're going to be criticized that's how
it goes he's a big boy he's getting 30
million plus per year he can take it
it's not the first time he's been
criticized in his career he woke it up
in the second half though look at those
numbers 23 of 29
244 yards three touchdowns in the second
half you mentioned the speech at
halftime
plenty of people i know who are steelers
fans was hoping that speech would be a
retirement speech from ben
roethlisberger
at halftime they were done with them i
mean the steelers fans and i
hey you start a season 11-0 and it all
falls apart i can understand the
frustration
but rothersberger found a way to will
the team to victory
great performance from him set aside the
first half it just made the second half
more memorable and more dramatic ben
roethlisberger best player on the field
all right let's uh flip it over to a guy
who seemed better
when you watched it again than you
thought he was when it was all unfolding
live on sunday
well mike i think it's jonathan taylor
and we kind of forget him
in in the rookie talk of of how good
these rookies are this rookie class and
it looks like an outstanding rookie
class
and he's one of those guys and he played
great i thought in this game and
after the first drive of the second half
the team had 25 carries for 117 yards
and he had 16 carries for 74 yards
and two touchdowns and the colts really
got away from the run after
that uh they only had three carriages
for 25 yards in their last five
possessions and probably why they lost
the game they should have turned to
taylor a little bit more he only
finished with 18 carries for 74 yards
and two touchdowns
but i thought he played a really solid
game
and they just needed to give him more
chances late mike
to have a chance to win the game yeah
for me
it's eric ebron just because this
narrative has really taken
root that he's not very good that he
drops too many balls and
look he's the last guy drafted before
aaron donald and odell beckham jr back
in 2014 and he's never going to live
that down at least not in my mind but
he had a solid game and he had one of
the touchdowns on the way back the
second touchdown that pulled it
to what was it at the time 24
24 72 made 24 21 my math is is
for a change correct 2421 and really
created the first sense that
the steelers are going to pull this damn
thing out and uh you know no drops
um reliable wheeled his way into the end
zone when he caught that pass down near
the goal line so i i got to give eric
ebron some credit because
that narrative really has taken root
that he's just kind of overrated
underachieving he had that one good year
in indianapolis they eventually moved on
from him the lions didn't care for him
and he'd been not as good as i thought
he was going to be this year in
pittsburgh but he was a key contributor
on sunday
in that unlikely win give me who had a
game
that they would like to forget shireen
well mike i thought it was the colts
secondary in the second half they had
four huge penalties there were three
defensive pass interference penalties
uh ended in an illegal contact and it
was 53 yards that that they flat out
gave the steelers and it was
for three different players xavier
rhodes had two of the penalties
uh tj kerry had one and kenny moore had
one and they really spread it around but
they did just
a terrible job uh has been through for
240 342 yards
and those three touchdowns and a lot of
that damage as we saw came in the second
half against the secondary that just
couldn't find a way to to get the
steelers off the field
yeah and i'm gonna stick with the unit
as well i thought about the front seven
of the colts defense but since you took
the secondary i'll give them a break i'm
gonna flip it over and one of the things
sims has been saying for the past few
years
with all this talk about the wall that's
being built
along our southern border he talks about
the wall that's being built
in indianapolis in the form of their
offensive line and
the wall did not hold on sunday against
the pittsburgh steelers
five sacks of phillip rivers the offense
went into a funk
you know when you get a lead like that
that's when
you you know we always talk about a
defensive line
pinning the ears back when they have a
lead well an offensive line when you've
got a lead that's their moment
to beat the other team's front seven
into submission and really find a higher
level and cement that victory
and and we can blame philip rivers and
blame the receivers and blame the
defense and blame this and blame that
but
to the extent that this is an elite
offensive line they didn't play that way
on sunday and i think they uh very much
would like to forget how things unfolded
all right one more topic coming out of
our re-watch
a play to take a closer look at shereen
which play of all the plays
in that game that game of two different
halves very different halves which one
did you select
well mike i don't think i've ever seen
this before but there's 104 left in the
game in the first half
and the colts faced the third down and
long
at their own 11 yard line and they
rushed up to line and tony romo made a
big deal out of this they rushed up to
the line like they were gonna quick snap
it
and go and the steelers had all three
timeouts and they don't call a timeout
and i'm just yelling at the tv time out
time out time out
and romo explained oh no they think the
colts are going to quick snap this ball
and they'll get a free time out well of
course they
didn't and i thought rivers really uh
snookered
mike tomlin there and they end up not
getting any points out of that the
steelers they drive down to the
uh colts 40 and they run out of time and
they went to the locker room with the
time out in their pocket and i thought
that was just a huge error on mike
thomas park
yeah and you know it's amazing that
rarely happens to mike tomlin but philip
rivers been around a long time very
savvy knows how to play those games and
from time to time manipulate the other
coach into
thinking that something is happening
that isn't happening
what registered for me and the game and
the play in the game that
that i think was clearly the turning
point after the steelers
drive down to the two and it's fourth
down and instead of taking the field
goal and making it 24 to 10 a two score
game at that point they decide
to go for the end zone and it doesn't
work and that was where
and on a sunday when i'm up here in the
studio watching the full grid of games
it is being piped in from connecticut in
the upper left corner was the steelers
colts game
right after that play that's when i say
okay you may as well turn that one off
this one's over
the steelers had their chance they their
backs have been broken
well that was when they woke up
defensively three and out
they get the ball on the indy 39 and on
that first play
after the offense had been so bad all
game long and ben roethlisberger has
been criticized for not getting the ball
down the field and randy fitner the
offensive coordinator criticized for not
dialing up more deep balls and it's not
working and guys are dropping and
deontay johnson
you know dropping everything that came
his way 39 yards
to the end zone deontay johnson laying
out he may be one of these receivers
that needs a higher degree of difficulty
so he doesn't think too much about the
catch
you know there's a lot of guys that if
it's if you're looking it in
and it's an easy catch you're more
likely to drop it when you just have to
go get it you don't think about it
and it worked and that was the turning
point of the game that was the moment
where the steelers had life
and i i've gone back and watched that
over and over and over again i mean if
they can stretch the field like
that in the playoffs and you have to
defend
that that's the kind of thing that's
going to help your running game open up
and it's going to keep that short
passing game from being smothered by
defensive backs who are anticipating it
as sims has said the steelers become
predictable in their predictableness
if you can stretch the field that way
and you can give opposing defenses
that on film to be concerned about
you have a better chance of your base
offense working more effectively and
specifically the run game sharing that's
what i continue to worry about
from the steelers perspective that run
game yeah 20 yards absolutely
for james connor uh and i understand the
game got out of hand for them and you
have to switch to the passing game but
but
old time steelers football is run the
ball run the ball run the ball run the
ball and they have got to discover that
in the playoffs or they are not going to
make it past the first round
and i don't think they will make it past
the first round mike unless they can
find that running game and i don't know
that they can this may be a one-and-done
team they did put together a second half
to get the postseason but now they got
to figure it out going into the
postseason and turn this thing around
turn this running game around if they're
going to continue into the postseason
with one game left
and there's so many permutations the
steelers would never admit this
but i suspect that they do not want to
cross paths with the ravens
in the wild card round because i believe
the ravens
number one or the better team number two
grossly outplayed the steelers in week 8
grossly outplayed them the steelers
somehow won the game
and then when they had that six day
delayed thanksgiving game
and the ravens didn't have lamar jackson
they were down this guy and that guy and
they'd gone through a week and a half of
a covet outbreak and they still kept it
close although 1914
is a little misleading because that last
touchdown was a garbage time
thing that made it closer and mike
tomlins ran after the game made it seem
like it was closer than it was but still
you give the ravens their full
complement of players
i think they can beat the steelers
especially at heinz field with no
fans there i think the steelers however
that board works out
you're if you're watching the scoreboard
and you're doing the math
and you're the steelers you want the end
result not to be steelers three
raven six steelers two raven seven you
don't want anything to do
with that outcome yeah i agree with you
mike i don't think they match up well
with the ravens i think they know that
and i think they would much rather have
the browns or
dolphins or whoever else they could
possibly get
than to face the ravens again
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports